you've got this show and you know I'm
jealous because you've got the show and
it's very funny and that's not the
reason I'm jealous because you're a
funny guy and you deserve to have a
funny show but then you decide I'm gonna
do a bit on my show with the weatherman
and Brad Pitt will be my weatherman and
you pull it off and I'm wondering how
the hell did you get breath it could be
your weatherman and then the other thing
I notice is that you had him on for a
while and then he's gone now we had him
on for 6 episodes it all kind of at like
Brad Pitt text me and said I want to be
on your show and I went alright I'll
think of something and then I went do
want to be my weatherman he was like
yeah great he was he was the weatherman
we had him on for about six episodes and
now he's not on the show anymore people
are complaining where is he gone well it
turns out he also has a movie career
like doing my little show isn't a focus
for him yeah but if it's County Central
they just after the first 10 episodes
they they had brought in test audience
to you know where people marked down
where they liked the show and they come
to us actually yesterday and they go
we've got the test results and I was
great they go people find you funny oh
my god that's good and they go people
really like Brad Pitt
and I go you need to test that did you
the women find him attractive I got a I
got a 9 out of 10 in the funny
Department there's things like looks
like you you've had these tests before
years ago we've done nine years but yeah
back in the early days and they were all
like no no this guy shouldn't have a
show good luck you're doing great well I
got a nine out of ten for fighting which
I thought was good but they wrote nine
out of ten means very or somewhat funny
anyway what is eight out of ten million
yeah he's five just like kill yourself
you